for a show about people who make a
podcast you'd think only murders in the
buildings after show would be a podcast
then they'd expect us to host it oh fair
enough
[Music]
mhm oh hello here I am again welcome to
one killer question the only murders in
the building after show I'm your host
Michael cirel
kraton this episode welcomes back Theo
uh Tober Theo Theo Tober what is it with
Mabel and all these teen names and which
one of them is Mabel's true soulmate you
know who I think has an answer Katherine
mcnamer Ryan brousard and James
cavarly welcome everyone thank you so
who does Mabel belong
with I'm going to start with you James
because I think you might have a very
interesting
answer I think it's
Theo perfect yeah you're like the the
the the most likable mistake murderer in
the you like mistakenly murder someone
out of all of the murderers we have in
the show you're my favorite it's true
it's always a joy to see you come back
our favorite murderer yes but I will say
if one something gets Mabel going it's
murder if Mabel feels attracted to Theo
then amazing awesome yeah and it was
such a huge plot Point too for season 2
where everybody thought Mabel was a
murderer for the longest time it's not
what you think and who understands that
more than anybody than Theo I think you
know there's obviously some kind of
chemistry and Spark between her and
tobert and and that is what it is but I
don't know there's a different kind of
intimacy and a different kind of
home she seems her most self when she's
with Theo I think yeah it almost feels
as though Theo is home to her in a way
oh yeah they've known each other other
since they were kids right yeah yeah in
in the same building right neighbor yeah
neigh neighbors not to get too deep but
LS they also both seem to be searching
for who they
are Theo is starting to grow and reveal
and become more of who he really is he's
the
developing and with
mael she's his only real friend the
person who he really connects with and
has had a relationship with yeah
yeah the only challenge is I'd say the
biggest thing that they bond over is
that they bond through their trauma yeah
I think I think Theo is always going to
be somebody who reminds her of something
that like she just never really really
got over so it's like you you got to
take that choice it's like do you do you
continue to you know face your past or
or be with somebody who's who's from
your past that's always going to remind
you of that thing or do you start fresh
and and and and kind of kind of put all
of that behind you listen it seems like
we're all pretty team Theo yeah it's
true
yeah Mr
deire but that doesn't mean tabbert's
not a good guy tobert is like new
exciting seductive also mysterious just
like Mabel well it's it's interesting
because having todber come in as a
completely new fresh thing it's
obviously exciting for Mabel and they
can relate on the career sense of things
and look any man who's willing to hide
in a Cupboard and talk about murder yeah
is is a good man he seems to be as
committed to kind of solving what this
murder is as much as Mabel is so I think
the big thing with tobert is he's
feeling something that she's is
obviously missing because she's so used
to being with that Trio and it's like
because they're kind of off doing their
own thing tobert is kind of filling that
hole also he has a very interesting
career yeah he's a creative person he
has a lot of passion I don't think I
know what Theo does for work do you
James I think Theo
probably is just really kind of a lazy
guy kind of sits at home watches TV
video games just kind of dead beat just
kind of chilling
back chilling on dad's money you know
well now you're making me Pro toer
yeah you convinced us otherwise no no no
no no I mean who wouldn't want to hang
out with tobert true true and would you
like brow down with tobert would you go
have some beers with
him well I me I mean have you seen his
eyes have you
seen
well this has been absolutely great I'm
so glad the four of us could chat about
this and on that note it's time to play
one killer game yes
huzzah so Matthew brodric is in this
episode digging way way way too deep
into the character of the Constable what
a conable from Nova Scotia Point like
this though from my research they were
trained to keep their hands Low by their
Firearms so they would Point like this
never like this but this and now it's my
turn Howard has been around the arconia
since day one so what we're going to
play is called ask Michael
anything James is going to spin this
wheel one of you is going to ask a
question any question you want about a
backstory of one of the characters that
inhabit om B I am going to answer that
question and if I don't know the answer
I am absolutely going to make it up
fantastic ready yes pretty good okay
James would you please spin the wheel
for
Ryan
oo oh no this is so much pressure this
is interesting so obviously we have the
whole brother thing um if t
or Oliver I guess would have to pick who
the favorite son is who would they be
and why favorite out of the boys yeah
yeah yeah out of the boys okay this is a
lot of pressure yeah well it kind of
answered it for me CU it's on Theo so
I'm going to say Theo is the favorite
cuz then I don't have to really make a
decision because I don't want to offend
anybody but okay so if they had to
decide
Teddy is gonna
pick will yeah as his favorite son
because he doesn't really know him he
doesn't really have to deal with him
right and I think Oliver has so much
room in his ailing heart yeah that he's
going to pick both of you y right that's
true that's good yeah that's pretty good
that's sweet I love that yeah yeah I'm
Switzerland neutral answer um all right
let's let's spin again for you
James
KT our stage manager James ask me any
question you want about KT's
backstory okay I have a
question in the show most of the
characters go to the pickle Diner right
when she goes to the pickle Diner what
would KT order straight up
Meatloaf um is what KY eats at the
pickle Diner all right James spin the
wheel for Catherine please all right
pressure is
on o Jonathan Jonathan Howard's
boyfriend yeah what do we want to know
about Jonathan's backstory when Jonathan
first met Howard what was the first
thing he noticed about Howard that made
him fall Head Over
Heels I can't even believe we're asking
this
question uh obviously the eyes the body
the hair the all of it no it's it was
dark it was in a blackout so no uh aside
from the looks of course what I think
Jonathan saw on Howard was a sort of an
open heart and an awkward conversation
style and he was Charmed by that I think
that's beautiful yeah we'll see we'll
hopefully we're together forever uh well
this was fun y I can't wait to see how
all of this turns out as we should
remind everyone any one of us except for
Catherine could be the killer no and
maybe we'll find out next time on one
killer
question have a good
[Music]
one